greetings from podcast value bad
[__] it's a whole new week with
a whole new set of rules Labor Day is
done and the [__] end line is coming
Christmas do you want to be broke anyway
who gives us talk about all that [__]
the church is brought to you by my
bookie listen if you found the yardstick
on the street would you pick it up or
would you keep walking come on you can't
be that much of a [__] [__]
of course you take the money so why do
you keep picking winners and not bet
them that's why I go to my bookie it's
fast it's easy and they pay when you win
listen what we're doing is this over my
bookie they're gonna double your first
deposit now today Monday the 9th not
[__] Tuesday the 10th not Wednesday
at 11:00 today we got action tonight you
use promo code Church they get a hundred
percent bonus on your initial deposit of
up to a thousand dollars are you [__]
nuts a thousand [__] dollars you put
down a thousand they give me a [__]
thousand visit my bookie dot AG that's
my bookie
dot AG for you [__] the mumbos grab a
pen I'll go slow my B oo ki e dot d ot
don't embarrass me AG and don't forget
to use the promo code Church when
creating your account to claim your
bonus all right listen with my bookie
you play you win you get paid
check the Instagram on Thursday that's
my Instagram my flavors world we'll be
talking about pics and I'll teach you
how to make you [__] better right
you'll be saying uncle Joey's my bookie
the church is also brought to you by
Express VPN internet privacy is dead you
know that and I know that this time
you're gonna get a plane ticket and you
got to click your [__] I credit card
and they already got it they already got
it they got yours your uncle's your
mother's they got everybody that's why I
use Express VPN expressvpn runs in the
background of your computer or phone and
then you use the internet like you would
normally would you download the app
click to connect
and voila you're [__] protected it
shields your identity no location
tracking and it's totally anonymous
you follow I'm saying to you so take
your internet privacy back today not
tomorrow not manana today and find out
how you can get three months free at
expressvpn comm slash Church CH you are
CH that's expressvpn dot-com slash
Church for three months free when you
buy the Year package visit expressvpn
dot-com slash Church to learn more and
take back your privacy Church is also
brought to you by CBD lion listen to me
when it comes to CBD products CBD lion
is the best how do I know go to cbn.com
and look at the third party lab results
and order it and after you take it for
30 days you'll be sending me [__]
emails on Twitter and Facebook saying
Joey I'm walking around like the sound
the [__] music I feel great yeah
[__] CBD line go to CBD line calm
right now
and press in church and get 20% off your
first order right
it's [__] Monday morning we're
playing for [__] keeps check this
[__] me delete this Monday you
bad [__] thank you for being
here in the church today is myself and
the Christ killer well I want to thank
you guys for support in the last couple
of weeks we've had some heavy-duty
guests with some heavy duty messages and
I always like when I have a guest has a
message for you guys that you guys take
something away whether it was rich Raza
Eliza James or [__] Matt Schulze
whatever Andrew Andrew Schultz my
favorite new [__] little man from New
York what I want to talk to you guys
about today I'm mistakes you know when
you make a mistake like I own it the
wrong shoes you know you make a right
turn and you [__] you know you get
back on that's a [__] mistake you know
today is nine nine nineteen this is a
really weird date for me nine nine
eighty nine was a dagger
married 30 [__] years ago today today
so for the last week I have really been
thinking about this like where I was as
a human being then and where I was as a
human being today because now I could
gauge it through that marriage and what
my thought process was and it's so weird
that that was the second biggest mistake
of my life she was a great girl and we
weren't supposed to be married I dated
for years before we got married and it
was just uh the whole four years like
the whole four years I was trying to I
mean I'll prepare this podcast and write
a little bit last night and I was just
thinking about it was just a crate I
mean we were together for four years and
we lived in five different states for
years so like did you think like a year
in like yeah we're having fun but I
won't marry I was 23 years old no okay I
wasn't even thinking about [__]
marriage I was 22 years old you're 23
years old you shouldn't be thinking
about marriage you haven't thought what
a girl you gone away from all weekend
everybody works everybody's got energy
to do [__] you're basically [__]
you're in love you're young nobody's
talking about marriage you know somebody
talks about it you shut it down and then
I was too busy to I was doing drugs I
was doing crimes
she was just my Bonnie and Clyde
whatever we were just a Bonnie and Clyde
team and I was with her for a long time
and the reason why I want to talk about
this is important because when you marry
somebody it's a [__] big big big big
decision you know I was speaking to a
friend of mine two weeks ago a very dear
dear friend I've known him since grammar
school and it was one of the saddest
calls I ever had because he told me he's
60 years old he's alone he doesn't know
what he did on this planet to be alone
he had been married five times for the
laughs he got married two times and one
year he married one chicken it lasted
six months the last chick
and he waiting for this one I mean I
love him today Lee and he's family and
stuff but I had a laugh she told him
that she was going home to visit her
father they got married and they were
together like two weeks and she told me
she was going home to visit her father
and then he got a divorce thing in the
mail you know he sees so now you're 60
and you're alone you know what nobody
wants to die alone when you're 20 you
like I don't give a [__] I don't need no
[__] I don't need no man I'll die like
Charles Bronson in a bunker listen
nobody wants to die along that and it's
so weird then I started before I started
dating this girl I had been on her and
I'm not ashamed to say it I had been
celibate for eight months and without a
girlfriend for a year like I was on a
really bad cold streak in my life I was
getting my life together
I will part of those part of that year I
was four months I was homeless so it's
tough to get [__] when you're homeless
you know I'm saying but it was one of
those years I was just having a bad year
and and it was funny I hadn't touched a
woman for like eight months and in three
days I was at three women when I got the
bulb like it was that fast I met a girl
on the plane the next day I went to get
an apartment I met a girl on the hill
then lit up and fool around with and
then I met some other girl and we dated
for two nights and I never saw her again
she lived on the other side of town it
was like when you don't need it it's
it's there it was just the way a weird
time in my life so I was just enjoying
both I was just living Boulder but back
to the case here
when I met her you know we just dated
then I went we almost broke up right
before I went to prison I got locked up
November 18th when I got charged that
was the day i kidnapped that dude like
November 5th
she had a hair thing she was cutting
hair and she having a cop
that she wanted me to go and I didn't go
I just didn't want to go it was looking
like a mile away it was like an hour
away and I didn't want to go and that
really hurt her feelings and that left
us some limbo
we weren't limbo for about two weeks and
I had seen her once or twice but the
relationship wasn't on good terms and
all of a sudden I got arrested so all of
a sudden she stayed loyal and she stuck
it out with me you know we work together
I'm getting all the paperwork done
everything that was due and you know she
helped me get my GED she drove me to
this place I mean it was just crazy
after that so that made this a little
tighter you know and then I got
sentenced and she didn't turn her back
on me then and Wow it's funny because
while I was in prison you know for four
years I was with her every day and then
I get locked up and now I'm not with her
and I gotta be honest with you it wasn't
like I was missing her during the week
and when she'd come to see me on Sundays
I was more concerned with what she
brought me than seeing her like it was
just really weird
so I thought when I got out that we
would to be honest here to be strictly
honest here cuz I was such a loser
my mental phases when I got out I'd [__]
up and we'd break up like I didn't want
to break up with her especially after
she was so nice to me and stuck it out
with me in prison and stuff but I knew
that the electricity wasn't damn like
it's not like I was right now love
letters every [__] day from prison I
wrote her a letter from time to time and
I'm being as honest as I can here but if
we were to be and this is happening to a
lot of the people listening for this
podcast at this point you're too far
involved and something inside he doesn't
want to say stop like a stop we should
be together but I was weird while I was
in prison she would come on Mondays and
I would call not to wear underwear and
[__] like that
and we would have sex we would eat
something come between you and me guys I
couldn't wait for her to get up and
leave that's not good no and it was it
was [__] with me
I just thought it was maybe something I
was going through because I was locked
up and then boom I get out and again
she's my world and we're hanging out and
she was a beautiful girl guys and she
had a great family who adopted me as
part of their family and they really
came through for me when the [__]
when I got locked up that's when they
really showed their true colors I mean I
always had my doubts that they even
liked me when I got locked up the mother
and dad bent over backwards for me so in
my mind I had a debt to pay them and the
debt was to come out of prison and be a
[__] good guy like their dad my
ex-wives dad and mom for that case with
good [__] white people out of Buffalo
I mean solid [__] polish people out
of Buffalo solid I mean I think about
them there's not a week that goes by I
don't think about him or her in some way
they had become my parents I was really
tight with her and after I got locked up
after the first time I went to County it
was her father who bailed me out
it was my girlfriend's father who bailed
me out and then we became tight we
became my father and son I would go up
to every saddling cut firewood with him
and we'd [__] bail hay and [__]
shovel snow and kill snakes you know
this is endless before I got locked up I
was very tight with so now I went to
prison he's sitting there with me in
prison when I when I was looking to get
out the judge was gonna Community
Corrections had ruled me out they voted
not to have me in Community Corrections
what that means is they don't want me to
be like Jeffrey Epstein they didn't want
me to go to work every day like
have a work-release program he [__]
wrote a letter and and paid my attorney
to do a special hearing to go in front
of the Community Corrections board to
accept me into a halfway house I mean so
these are all the little things they did
for me so in the back of my mind I was
indebted to their family in a big way
and I had to pay that debt so I put my
head down I got out of prison I got a
good job and listen man I was not like I
was robbing a kidnapper all that [__]
was behind me well the only thing I was
still fighting with my demons who wear
the drugs and everybody knew that like
she knew it I don't think the parents
know it the parents had known of my drug
use but didn't know my drug use at the
time she knew about my drug use and we
you know sometimes we think it's gonna
get better you go buy a car and you walk
in and you go I want the car to be baby
powder blue and the guy goes I don't
have it in blue I have it in [__] uh
canary yellow and you're like well I
mean I don't like that color but the guy
says to you what if I lowered the price
$600 would you like to call it better
and you're like yeah we lowered it for
600 I would and you take the car you
take the car you drive the car you're
happy with the car but at the end of the
day it's not the car you wanted yeah you
save 600 and you you know you won't have
to dinner with three and you put three
in the back but it's not really the car
you wanted that's I want you to think
about that it's not the car you wanted
we do this in life sometimes we go along
with some it's not really what I wanted
but let me go along with it you know
when you serve an apprenticeship nobody
wants to serve our [__]
apprenticeship nobody wants to do four
[__] years digging wires and [__] -
[__] five bucks an hour
- gets bit by spiders
slaves and [__] like that but you know
at the end of the four years you're
gonna have a career you know so that's
why if you get into one of those careers
you want to make sure you love all this
[__] but what I'm trying to say is this
that I was indebted to their family so
when I got out I tried my hardest the
only problem I had was my addiction I
thought that in time like buying a car
and saving 600 I thought that in time I
would get used to the car you know I'm
saying and we all do that we all do this
at one point in our lives and we let
learn a valuable lesson I didn't do it
with a car I did it with a human being
what bothers me the most about just
thirty years looking back was that I did
something I didn't want to do that
I was raised not to do which is to tell
people what you feel and if you don't
want to do something don't do it you
know I got caught in the fog that I if I
would have sat her down like a man and
said listen I love you but I'm not crazy
gaga over you like I'm not I don't know
it was I think it was too soon after my
mom's death something was not right for
my feelings towards her well I don't
necessarily believe in soulmates but I
think there's some things that it just
worked with someone it could be like a
job like this ending with a car
everyone's taking drug jobs or gone to
the same school school you don't really
want to go through all that [__] we all
do those things we all do those types of
things but they involve us like I'm a
firm believer and listen I don't mind
walking down a dark alley but I'm not
taking you with me
yeah I don't want you to do it to me so
I don't do it to people yeah me picking
the wrong car that's on me for later me
putting somebody through what I did was
not the right case
so instead of me sitting her down and I
didn't I'd it how the [__] do you know
when you're a love totally in love with
somebody you really don't I I don't know
it's like when you first meet somebody
those first that first year you're
walking on clouds you're whistling you
know and then you get into an argument I
don't [__] know I don't know if we
were used to each other I don't know if
because I lived with her for a while
that we had already felt through a
married couple I know I love to but I
didn't know so I'm in a halfway house
it's 89 we're seeing each other you know
every other day we're gonna I'm you know
I'm between the halfway house because I
had excuse me I had time to leave the
halfway house and come home every day
you know I had hours drop today so I'd
meet him in certain times sometimes we
had sex sometimes they just had lunch
and one day we're by a mother south from
her for a hike and I gave her a stabbing
of the mountains you know we're just
walking around it was a nice day in
April or something I just gave her ass
to happen and a month later she came
back to me and told me she was pregnant
and I gotta tell you he round was out of
prison you know really didn't have it
together by no means I knew how to make
money I know how to make you know sixty
thousand years seventy thousand a year
that's what I was capable of making but
I didn't know anything else of my life I
knew nothing else when she told me she
had the baby I could honestly tell you
guys at one point at all and not even
one point I think I'm aborting the baby
or anything I'm from the old school
you know she told me she was pregnant I
asked her what she wanted to do and she
said that she would feel better if we
got married so it was like something
that didn't have a time to think about
it it's it's funny we have a running
joke Lee and I that I bust his balls so
every couple weeks ago I'm showing the
woman I love my town
there was on one night Lee and I were
having a discussion about something I'm
likely would have [__] law and he's
think I'm in Boston with Paul and I'm
showing the girl I love them possibly
gonna marry in my hometown I'm like this
poor bastard then till his dad bust his
balls about it because he doesn't know
how close he came to being me and
whether he understands or not that I was
busting his balls when you said that to
me that this is possibly the girl I'm
gonna marry I'm a man having that knot
in my stomach like I did when I got
married because you don't know about
this not till you get married it's it's
a terrible night and we all know about
the night when we're doing something we
don't really want to do you know was the
same not wait well me know you and I get
what you're saying that it's not it was
not nice to bring her along but you
wrote you guys were both young and I I
didn't I didn't realize that I wasn't
supposed to marry Paula until after we
broke up whoa like looking back at like
yeah no but here's the funny thing that
guys like you and I believe Society yeah
okay
this is why I just I wanted to do this
podcast because I wanted to tell you
that society I wanted to tell you all
the wrongs of society you know a little
unwritten rules of society that are
meant to be broken
they're not solid and paper than that
these are unwritten rules that we
believe that I've broken that I know for
a fact you could break them you know you
were young when you met Paul I believe
you had just been out of a relationship
for you I mean there's so many different
situations that go into a relationship
when you see them you know when I [__]
when she told me I had to marry her like
she didn't tell me I had to marry that
we should get married
I went along with it I went and got the
rings of her we shut up the thing and
for three months I worked so drugs and I
did everything I could to make it done
everything I could to make a dollar
I sold book a Clips cars Mitsubishi
Eclipse is at sticker price
I was selling tons of blow at the
halfway house I was loan sharking money
at the halfway house I was doing a
thousand things because I didn't even
know what a husband was do you have a
saying like how could you you're 25 I
didn't know what a husband was no but
that's not no excuse see that's the
excuse we always tell ourselves with 25
were 18 when 19
there's tons of 19 year olds that made
it work there's a ton of girls that I
went to high school with that are still
with the guys they dated in high school
and are they happy they're together
cuz that like that's the thing cuz you
hear all those sides like 50% divorce
and my parents didn't have a good
marriage
I see people my age or younger getting
married I'm like why I feel like maybe
if you waited longer and learned what
you actually wanted marriages would last
longer well this is what we're getting
to you is that I married her and I mean
guys I gotta tell you something that
whole summer I was excited I couldn't
wait for September 9 to come like Jesus
Christ my parents orphaned my [__] I
dropped out of high school I mean I
failed everywhere else basically [__] I
got this right I went to prison I got
out she's got a great family she's a
great girl
[__] I hit a home run now all i gotta do
is cover a certain not every month and i
can basically do whatever I want
I had a chick that does laundry for me
and somebody to suck you dead
and you know and when you're 25 and
you're an animal like me that's what
you're thinking about I'm not gonna sit
here and pamper in a pretty body to make
you feel good that's what we think of
young men
well yeah we got somebody to do laundry
and somebody to cook for us and you know
now we could still run our game oh I'm
still gonna go to Vegas and we on a
weekend to drink really you can't do
that [__] when you're married you know
but I the whole summer I was off site
for the wedding I had a best man I had a
[__] I had uh some of my friends are
coming out from Jersey we rented this
[__] courtyard married and it was on
it was [__] on I was still in the
halfway house guys I'm gonna [__]
halfway house and I had to get a judge
because I got released from the halfway
house maybe a week before I got married
so they sent some then they wanted to
look at my this is some crazy [__] they
wanted to look at my guest list from the
wedding so they made me hire a boulder
police officer this is crazy [__]
because I was still in the Community
Corrections and then there was gonna be
alcohol being served there was some
crazy [__] at my wedding so you weren't
allowed to drinking your way no but I
still snorted coke nobody really knew
towards the end I still was snorting
coke my friend showed up and we got
there we got married at this place
called Sacred Heart in Boulder and the
priest his name was father Tom I loved
this [__] and you know I did the
marriage classes I did the whole [__]
thing me I mean I was all in number two
you gotta remember my other thought
process at the end of the day guys no
matter what the [__] I tell you I'm
Catholic a marriage is a [__]
sacrament so I had skipped over
confirmation right I had done baptism my
first communion and I don't know what
else that's it I still had seven more to
go the last tour
you know you get buried in the anointing
of the sick but marriage is up there
somewhere
so I took the classes I mean guys I was
all in I thought I was all in and why
didn't they came we got to the church my
best man showed up he was up for two
days before he got me he had coke rings
around his nose so they wouldn't let him
stand the priest came up to me cuz the
priest father tom was a drug counselor
up in San Francisco ain't there were
people on drugs look like so he pulled
me aside he listened this guy can't
stand then he's got rings around his
nose Joey sighs okay so I had my best
friend Georgie who I still talk him on
the podcast all star frames and close
eye part I had him stand in for Mike
Ronnie and I got what married and stuff
but I don't know if you guys can follow
college football what was Saturday's
biggest college football game was the
Brassica Colorado at Colorado let me
tell you something when Nebraska plays
Colorado Colorado the whole state shoot
shuts down but Boulder really shuts down
when they play in Boulder the city
completely rundown if you put a mask on
like the Hamburglar and a jacket and get
a gun with a bag you can rob every
business because nobody gives a [__] the
cops don't even react when the Colorado
Buffaloes the playing Colorado is a
big-time football state and it's a cow
cop countin the cow
it's a fun cowboy it's a it's a football
city I got married if you look at the
camp review today's September 9th who
played on September 7 Nebraska Colorado
at Colorado Wow so I I got married on
the day of the Colorado and Nebraska
wedding unbeknownst to me I never even
thought about it
when you get married on the date
nobody's paying attention even the
priest wasn't paying attention he just
he just read off the cue card what's the
score you
like nobody gives a [__] so I didn't
know so we get back to the courtyard
marry it
my friends are coked up to the gills
they're [__] doing bumps there
there's a little lounge and they kept
telling the guy at the lounge where's
the TV and the guy's like we got no TV
and they're like how the [__] don't you
have a TV in the lounge here's my
girlfriend's family her family came in
from Buffalo they're all nice white
polish people they ain't bothered nobody
here's my friends I'll there mind having
an argument with the hotel staff about
no [__] TV at the bar so one of my
buddies said [__] this he sent one of
the [__] guys
bellman to a hardware store but make my
mcduck ins mccoggins mcgucket's he sent
them to a hardware store on Bal the name
the guck ins where he got an extension
cord and my other buddy paid for a hotel
room they took the TV out of the hotel
room and put it on the table at the
wedding and while we were dancing half
the people were circled around the table
watching the football game at the
divorce my wife brought that issue up
that's how hot my wife got about my
friends unbelievable so my wife but I
heard getting hot at that wedding it
kind of pissed me off a little bit that
day I don't know why like for her to
like and I get it it's your biggest day
in LA but she knew when she was married
she knew that was sad and she knew she
hadn't met half my friends already she
knew they were savages here's what one
warrior went here's what gets [__]
weird so I married her I say yes we're
at the reception guys were having a
great time the food is great you know
family's great and we were going to go
to San Francisco now I was on probation
they told me they looked at my face
Friday and said when you get back on
Tuesday what time you get back and I was
like I think I get back I get to they
want you think they said to me right off
the bat
and they got a George a judge to sign
the order they were like we want you to
go home unpack and be in our office by
5:00 to submit a urine sample whoa and I
said that's gonna be no problem if I got
high on Friday night I would have been
fine oh it's that fast buck oh yes 72
hours Danaher had time so that Friday my
bachelor party was basically me George
and my brother-in-law Joe and we got
like two eight balls and four cases of
beer and we just sat in my living room
and got high watching MTV videos that
was my bats apart there was no girls
there was little strippers nobody got
chiseled it it's nothing like that
it was just three guys we just sat there
overnight and talked and then at one
time George left and my brother-in-law
told me he was happy that we didn't opt
for an abortion that that meant a lot to
him and blah blah blah
so I was really happy and now came the
day of the wedding I had to keep it
under control
but at about 6 o'clock I did my first
line you know just to join in I wasn't
allowed to drink at my wedding but I
snuck a couple glasses of champagne just
to get a little alcohol on me and then
we the plan was to take like the seven
o'clock flight out of that Denver
Stapleton and go to San Francisco and
then Sunday we're gonna go to the
Yankees against the Oakland A's with
Canseco and that whole team and then
Monday night we're gonna go to Monday
Night Football
it was a giant against the San Francisco
49ers for the season opener okay so this
is Laura's tale and Joe Montana this is
tremendous so on the plane we get on the
[__] plane the seven o'clock plane to
San Francisco and it's not too full it's
kind of on the empty side so we sit in
the back she had what do you call those
stockings with the nylons know the ones
that girl's way to look sexy oh I I
there's another word for now
pantyhose pantyhose with the [__]
clips and the whole weapons and the holy
gardener thing like either she had a
garter belt on and she was beautiful she
my ex-wife was a beautiful girl and
right there on the plane dogs we started
[__] on the plane Jesus like an aisle
like 18 there was nobody around us and I
just bent throw with doggystyle the
aisle and we just started [__] and
then she got on top me we started
[__] and oh yeah who are the flight
attendants they were minding their own
business there's like the late flight
out I think we 69 the little bit of the
flight we did it all me that she was she
had to be let me see she was four months
pregnant oh my god we were doing
everything she didn't do blow she didn't
know about my drug use see I was lying
to her already like she did not know it
what a [__] weekend she knew that she
was doing coke with me for four years
she knew that I would get pale and my
neck would start [__] rumbling around
and [__] so after we finished having sex
on the plane she made a comment and if I
tell you this guy is you not gonna
believe this for right there I knew the
marriage is over Wow like as I was
sitting there looking at her I started
realizing the mistake I had made like
one minute we were having sex and now we
were sitting she was sitting by the
window and I was in the Al seat we had
the middle one open and it just gave us
like we had that that last 45 minutes to
reflect on what we had done and it
wasn't pretty
do you think she was feeling the same
way
looking back I don't know I think you
know we both weren't look I saw her
after we broke up and stuff and you know
for four years I made her life hell but
I could tell she was a little happier
she had
she was more secure as where she was
with me there was no security blanket
I'm the type of guy that I could leave
it to a clot I'm not go get arrested for
something you won't see me for ten years
but that was my life you know but I knew
at that moment that that marriage wasn't
gonna work on that point and then to add
to put the weather they said well you
underlined the word except for sighs you
know emphasized what I did we drove to
the hotel I rent to the 240z acts of
Nissan that's what they gave me arts we
drove to the hotel we checked in like I
said she was four months pregnant so
this is a long day for her she checked
out she would she sound asleep I went
into the other room sat there for ten
minutes and I was like [__] this and I
went and I went through a shitty
district the San Francisco by the
Tenderloin and there was a bar where a
friend of mine I thought that I knew
from five years earlier four years
earlier his name was bamboo see I went
over then I picked up an Eightball phone
and I went back to the [__] car into
a garage at the hotel
I must have bought a 12-pack and I just
drank and slaughtered the whole a fault
that's the Lee it was midnight and
anybody was listening to this knows I
did three that was how high my town
which was in 1990 I did it 8ball from 12
o'clock at night it's a six in the
morning then I was just drinking beers
pissing outside the car there was no
cameras downstairs
I must have pissed 20 times I pretty
much finished the eighth ball I must
have jerked off three times in the car I
got on the elevator at 1:00 and I took
my clothes off I laid down and as I laid
down she goes how did you sleep
she didn't even know I was gone but I
told her I didn't sleep good can I sleep
one more hour
I took one hour sleep and then we had to
get up and go to Oakland to watch the
[__] produced an afternoon game [__]
my point being that I [__] know like
my Holly moon that was that was my
[__] honeymoon
you know I pretty much went to do a
[__] eight ball and how long you said
those are your hind but how long did he
stay married I stayed back I mean I got
back to the honeymoon in September
September whatever we got back the night
we must have got back the 12th and we
were separated 11 months later let me
see
no we were separated we got separated in
91 because the baby was born in Maine d
so just over a year so 18 months so we
pretty much lasted the marriage lasted
two years until we called my first and
here's the sad day that once we but we
got home it was I we got right back to
our shitty [__] lives our life she
was a struggling hairdresser she was
striving to get customers this [__] like
that and I was just a [__] junkie
trying to find something to make money
with I had no problems making money but
the unhappiness of what I had done and
once the baby was born I was really
unhappy like I was unhappy with myself I
was on I wasn't unhappy with the child I
was now I really loved that child with
all my heart I just didn't like our home
I could you could tell there was no love
in that home you know I had never lived
well what my mom died I lived in homes
you know I lived at the Bender's who had
a great home and there was a lot of love
I lived with the rummies who weren't as
financially off as as well as the
Bender's but there was still a lot of
love in the home you know you could tell
when there's no love in a home and it's
all
horrible and it's a horrible horrible
feeling to be involved in a home with
it'll there's no love you know it's
gonna Buster than a day and I think with
us like when we got back we realized
what we're gonna do but we kept playing
out to see if this would change like
having the kid would change it something
would change it on and and I gotta be
honest here I got frustrated by life I
was listening to Oz he's boneyard
Theoden there's a guy Billy something no
interviews Ozzy every once in a while
and they were talking about jobs how
many jobs Ozzy had had he talked about
working for a butcher and this that and
this and and it's weird how he made this
statement that I don't want anybody
who's listening to get offended by this
statement but it's a feeling you get if
and if you're an artist right now or
there's something that you want to know
this is the feeling that I'll hit you
first
the first that comes to your mind is is
this it one morning one day when you get
home and you kiss your kids and you hug
them and you look at your wife and your
wife tells you then it'll be ready in
five minutes hon and you take off your
Construction boots and you take off your
socks and you stretch out your feet a
little bit you take off your sweaty
shirt and you look at your [__] hands
at one point every man asks themselves
is this it is this as good as my life is
gonna get this is it I'm gonna work six
days a week I'm gonna have one day off
and this is what I'm gonna do
every man at one point pastor every
human being
hasta I mean if you have a living [__]
anything in your mind
you have to ask yourself a question is
this it I go to work five days a week I
give my wife money on Friday all my
money for these three [__] [__]
kids I get had with her she's getting
fatted by the [__] day my boss sucks
my Foreman is busting my balls I'm
behind on my credit card I owe my
parents two thousand dollars you know
just you you put all the problems of the
world that you're gonna have anyway but
you ask yourself is this it is this as
good as I gonna get and two things
happen from there you put your head down
and you go this is it or you pick your
head up and you go how can I make my
life more enjoyable to live when I die I
want to be on that deathbed going Jesus
Christ this ride was worth it I don't
want to be on a death day going wow I
was cool I [__] was in prison for 40
of my 60 years I knew I didn't want that
you know but I know that me living with
her in the situation I could speak for
her also if my ex-wife was sitting
across from me she tell you - she was
just as happy as I was there's nothing
worse than having a home that doesn't
have love in it and then being unhappy
ours is unhappy as she was if bro I'm
gonna tell you something right now and
you [__] know I feel about
Scientology I can't stand those
[__] when I see them with a
little blue shirt the little pens in
their pockets the Hollywood Boulevard I
want to take the pen and stabbed in the
neck like John wick I was so weak at
that point that the Scientologists could
have got me well I was so emotionally
weak that that's when you join cults
that's when you join Pablo's Church of
Escobar ISM on the corner and some guy
comes in a Cadillac and he pulls up with
three holes all over got diamonds on
meanwhile you're [__] working at
McDonald's and you giving him half your
stipend
every week you know I'm saying thank
those people coming to your life
hey your weakness like I was emotionally
that week because I didn't have an
answer for my unhappiness I did not have
an answer for my unhappiness I keep
thinking about your friend that you
brought up at the beginning who's been
married five times
like do you think like like him looking
at you like you better I would never
have gotten divorced like like he's just
looking for he's looking the same thing
that you're talking about but he's just
doing it by marrying the first woman who
talks to him listen any education when
you last night the Boston two nights ago
what Saturday night I don't know
whatever the Boston Red Sox lost to the
Yankees five to one at home I think it
was saddening that somebody on the
Boston Red Sox learn something from that
loss learned something they said okay
I'm not gonna throw the ball this way
from now on Jesus I should have thrown
the ball to first every time you lose
you were you're making me Allah lately
you were making me how the other night
because Lee calls me on the way back
from his jinx and he tells me his
experiences my laugh because these are
the experiences that you get yeah man he
was having a good Sonny so he said
something a waitress and that the scent
went kaput
you know he said he went up to his show
the other night and there was it was an
outdoor show you know this is why I sent
you that you have to do this journey
this journey is so important because you
live and you learn from a journey when
that unhappiness I had with that woman
and it wasn't listen I could sit here
and tell you she made me unhappy no no
no I was unhappy with myself we this has
gone back to frustration because I know
I wasn't doing the right things and then
I was unhappy in my marriage my hope my
home wasn't happy I wasn't happy at all
nothing was right
and I have lingering in my mind was that
stand-up [__] I had that stand-up [__]
as an ace-in-the-hole like maybe that
could save me well it's not gonna save
me
stand-up isn't gonna say my stand-up
isn't going the way anything for me
stand-up is just gonna be something I
try and do for a year and then I quit
like everything else that quit in my
life that's what I'm gonna do
that's the same [__] I'm gonna do all
the time stand-up was just something but
I was looking for so much like I just
needed something to fill this [__]
void in my heart here I had and here's
the funny thing I had a job was I
getting was I was I was I'm getting rich
not really but I was keeping the lights
on and they were paying me a lot more
than I was qualified I'll tell you that
much I'm honest enough to tell you that
they'll pay me a ton more and I was
qualified so I took it I did the best
job I could I work on everybody else and
I shut my mouth I had a car I mean I had
a home I had a beautiful wife I had a
daughter
I don't know how long it went that I
didn't even touch her what do you mean
like wouldn't have sex like the last
year before we separate it was to that
point
we were just sleeping together we were
just two roommates I had a baby
lesbians have more action you know I
mean it was that uncomfortable and I saw
the movie punchline and I [__] got on
stage on whatever July 18th and when I
got off stage I knew this is what I
wanted to do and through the grace of
God three months later she found the
[__] because I didn't have even
though I was unhappy and frustrated I
didn't have the courage of the balls to
tell I want to get a divorce I didn't
tell her
and the reasons were there were two
reasons number one I was a loser
I couldn't imagine living through this
life without somebody to fall back on
I couldn't imagine I could not imagine I
didn't have that the self calm I had the
confidence who the [__] am I kidding
I just had fear to fall back on myself
you know it's really weird when a woman
leaves a man and and she has a kid and
you know she makes a statement and and
she doesn't she [__] gets two jobs
and she raises those daughters or sons
and everybody's happy and they become
they get this certain freedom you know I
was [__] scared to go pull the
trigger because I had a father to lose I
had the mother lose I would want my
daughter I would have lost all the
security that I had because that's what
I looked at them as as [__] security
I didn't look at them as you know and
don't get me wrong till today
mr. mr. King ray King rest his soul he
was if I learned a lot from him how much
maybe none at all because you didn't
have your mom and your dad wasn't there
and he said you had a great relationship
with our family how much were you just
like like wanting a family at that point
Dave fictive they filled the void for a
long time I mean I was just walking
there I could go up there with a hot
hair and hang with them parents and I
would I would get mad at the other
brothers and sisters not spending as
much time with their family as they
could I mean there was just a lot of
things that I was scared to break off
the relationship you know when I came
home that October 15th and she said she
wanted to talk to me in the kitchen and
tell me that you know she didn't want to
date me I should
separation I was very sad because of my
daughter
but at the same time I was very happy
because I would have never pulled the
plug I mean don't get me wrong I wanted
to do comedy I wasn't in love with her I
was in love with her but very we would
it was just like a forceful love it was
like I was in love with her from a debt
you know I own her a debt that's the
only reason why I was in love with her
so that was the second time in my life I
did something against what I wanted to
do Ellen and I learned the hard way this
was not just a mistake this was
something that stuck with me forever
you know I was raised listen you have
those guys of like hey man what are we
doing tonight now we're gonna go over to
Johnny's place but before we go to
Johnny's place we'll wheel over pick a
leashing ball because that [__] [__]
works then he'll give us a few drinks
for free I'm the type of guy if I don't
like that [__] I'm not going over there
get free drinks from I don't care the
[__] figures your free drinks if you
don't like them don't hang out you don't
have to deal with them in no level
there's so many people that Walker
especially in Hollywood then just your
friend because it makes them look good
that they don't really like you they
don't care about who you are they don't
care about your family they don't care
about nothing like that I wasn't raised
if I don't like you we don't like each
other you go your way and I'll go the
other way won't even have to [__]
talk it's it's understood but no you
know what my mother died I loved about
xenos I love the bowels a nose I love
the Garcias I loved every battle out
with John Bend asked me to move in with
him hey I love John like a brother but I
didn't love John enough and I want to
hang out
every day do you know I'm saying what so
when I moved in with him I thought he
wanted me to hang out with him every day
I didn't want to hang out with nobody
I had my buddies I hang out with and I
did stuff with that was a big mistake me
moving in with John because yeah three
quarters to me with he was using him in
a way three quarters of me was you and
don't get me wrong I love this father
Jimmy been the senior god rest his soul
I loved his brothers I loved his sister
I just John I loved John like a brother
I just did not want to hang out with him
and because of my behavior and whatever
that added to it but that was a big
mistake
and the second big mistake that I made
and I learned from the most was getting
married when I wasn't head-over-heels
because thinking about it now today
dirty is later I was not head over heels
let me tell you something I've been with
my wife now this joy I will be 20 years
and I could look you all in the face and
tell you one thing I'm not perfect but
I'm loving my wife I love my wife and I
loved them before she had that kid I
when I realized how much I loved my wife
I called her on the phone and proposed
to her while she was at work and we got
married six weeks later you know I knew
what love was from not from knowing what
not loving somebody was it took me nine
years to propose to my wife
Wow nine years because one I was so
pissed off after work at the sacrament
of marriage that we I got married and I
[__] it up I'm the type of guy that
once I do one thing one time that said I
[__] it up I don't want to be involved
with it no more so I got married I
[__] it up and I never wanted to get
married again because I didn't want to
ruin somebody's time I didn't wanna
[__] my wife now is a sweetheart will
complete out
you guys have seen it on the previous
podcast I've had it on twice if you see
it her and I standing together you will
walk up I can go what are you doing with
this lunatic you don't belong with this
guy we mixed and I truly was in love
with it it took me eight it took me four
years to realize I was a lover
it took me seven or eight to realize how
much in love with her I was I proposed
to her and now I'm very very much in
love you follow me do not get me wrong
I'm not the perfect husband
you know like we've said before on the
podcast if I see a flying [__] flying
around the end he just comes down and
bites me in the dick I'm not gonna turn
it down I'm not I'm not the [__]
poster boy for whatever I'm a good
husband I provide I love her very much
I'm home with them [__] 80% of the
time my wife knows where I am
every [__] minute of the day I'm
gonna live in my own personal [__]
prison and between meetings the
kickboxing school the gym krile the weed
store here I'm only in a couple [__]
places I don't do much but having that
failure made me a better husband today
but I gotta tell you something
I didn't like that failure that was one
of the failures I didn't like I don't
mind the prison thing the prison thing
wasn't a failure that was a flaw in my
personality and I had Justin I never
went back to prison again those are
completely different things I considered
my first marriage a failure I got a bad
fever got an F in school an F - that's
the lowest thing you did get we
understand I got an F - that's why I
learned that if I ever did it again I'd
get an A+ and today as a husband I don't
get an a-plus I got an A
all right like before I didn't take the
garbage out on the way out I was
supposed to take the garbage out but I
already had one handle of a duffle bag
and
was carrying something else if I got
something for you that I forgot to give
you a box of a meal Hido food all right
do kettlebell food they gave us set this
food to sample so I want to give you
that but anyway back to the story that
the failure I had as a husband the first
time made me a light now I look at all
the little things all the little things
of of merits that I focus on that even
consider focusing on the first time if
you're going to get married and you're
young just do me a big favor do yourself
a worksheet write it out I'm and few
women listening you're going on Joey's
putting the [__] a [__] what was
that a snake in my coil
I'm also he's putting a [__] snag in
my nail well that no I'm not I'm talking
to you too you don't want to marry the
wrong [__] guy you don't want to
marry somebody because they have money
or they're good-looking or their parents
own the company or you know their mother
is so sweet look to the main purpose of
this marriage
and that's do you love this person to
spend the rest of your life with them
and to look them in the face every
[__] day don't say to yourself all
I'll learn to love her you know
mmm would leave first father moved in a
couple months went by you guys were
happy I didn't say nothin tear and then
one thing I said some to you and you
gave me a little like 9 minute speech
about the things you didn't like but you
were tolerating yeah it's turns I told
you go there and have it just tell it no
more you know we laughed about you know
what she doing here and all that stuff
with the mother but I was being serious
with you
because it was such when you marry
somebody get that [__] out of the way
early if they put their feet on your
furniture you don't like it tell them
right off the bat I don't want that
freed on your front you know there were
all little things that I already knew
that Lee it wasn't gonna work for me
before we moved there in
I totally it wasn't gonna work for him
because we likes his space but I'm I'm
glad I did it because work we got
married without her living together I I
think I think it's important to like
really test things out well no no you
have to I think before you marry
somebody I got no qualms at that I got
no problems at that what have you date
something for four years and then you
marry him then you find that when they
[__] it smells like a giant Annette open
up every window like Matt she's gonna
walk around the house like you're
looking for Frankenstein one of those
porches with not another I am you know
but at the time Eden II thought a
movement I can just tell you you were
just not going to adjust right yeah I
looked at you and had seen that no
offense
even though you're Jewish she's never
said well it's the same money I want a
roommate situation right most people in
this town would say I want a roommate
situation you never even thought you
were like if I could pay the full Vig
I'll [__] pay it just not to have
somebody in my space that lets me know
something about you
second lets me know that your space is
really [__] important to you you know
and guess what we why I know is because
when I got married I knew how important
that space was to me yeah you're not
ready to get married
unless you could share that space yeah
it's a big [__] space to she start
getting mad I start getting mad about
the way she would put stuff in cabinets
it's crazy it's crazy it marriage is a
crazy thing if you've been married and
you fail hey you learn something about
it don't get turned off by it
don't say I'm no good married again it's
all about to stay
just a piece of paper [__] that it's not
it's a lifestyle and it could be
beautiful the problem is you gotta put
the work into it you gotta put the work
into it the only difference we my
marriage now you want a hundred percent
difference how listen when I first had
jack one I loved that little girl
anybody who knows anything about me
knows I love women at how I feel about
that I love that little girl me and the
mother did not see eye-to-eye from that
kid being six months old I knew when
that child was six months old I had to
figure out what I was gonna do because I
didn't like the mother anymore
and today look at where I am today so
today where are we 30 years to the
anniversary I paid for this mistake I
paid for this mistake dearly this was
not like making a right turn and ending
off and [__] red eyes this was a
mistake that followed me for 30 years it
was such a bad mistake
hey I chalk it up to experience I
chalked up to one of the things you do
in life and I chalk it up to just the
person who I was then 30 [__] years
ago today right now well Monday uh god
knows where the [__] I was I was
probably headed over to the reception
and I was such a different person such a
different person but till this day I'm
paying for that mistake I would not want
any of you guys to go or what I went
through with this mistake so before
women guys before you think of getting
married even though you have a great
time we have a great time we went away
we went to Ricky's mom Beach there's no
Beach and [__] you Pismo Beach
I still like people yes right I see how
much you go now no you might as Walt is
every time you've gone with somebody
else been a [__] disaster
what vacation it's a beach an hour and a
half away
what vacation his nose an hour and a
half away it's not a vacation don't they
have an open mic in Pismo I've had the
best pizza in Pismo he went all the way
to Pismo to get the worst beats in the
[__] world
and sit in the room call him up see if
they'll do it open mics you [__] sure
they were at the pizza but listen man
just for today if you're not in love
with something don't [__] do it
hey I know it's time I know you're
saying Joey what the [__] are you
talking listen if you know totally and
[__] love don't do it and if you
think you aren't you know you have been
in love you've been dating somebody can
you break up and after two we show Ike
this isn't that bad I don't even I
didn't even like her that much I just
like the way she suck my dick or you
know for women [__] I just like them
less his family and money and I would
have been financially secure listen
financial security blow jobs jobs houses
nothing beats happiness I rather be
unhappy I'd rather live in a [__]
with somebody I love then live in a
mansion with somebody I don't want to be
around because whether you have a shack
a one-bedroom Shack or you have a 14
bedroom mansion the most important thing
is for it to feel like a home and for it
to be happy what good is having all that
[__] that's why when I see people having
weddings with pigeons people dressed in
white I could call the days on that
divorce there's there's too much pomp
there's too much circumstance is too
much smoke and mirrors
I want it you know this isn't about
smoke and mirrors a home you'll know
when a home is right I know a lot of you
[__] I smoked I'm a Sarah Tiana
I spoke about a lot of people and evenly
for what when your house was good it was
good now when it was a Hallman was a
home somewhere along the line you follow
straight off the reservation
your mother was unhappy your mother was
more
and your dad was a John Travolta haha
and old Sam that liar he was doing this
going this [__] people break up for
certain [__] reasons I don't think
your dad looks at it as a mistake
you know he had two beautiful boys from
it whatever whatever there's always a
you I mean there's always positives to
it always the [__] so Booker III just
from my point of view as a kid is like
because I hear that a lot
I'll let's stay together for the kids to
me I had wished my parents got divorced
ten years before they did you could feel
oh it was worth it there's a lot of
anxiety in the house you can it never
like holiday start being bad because
like there's gonna be a fire I get it I
get I get the thought process behind
stay together for the kids but I don't
ya know I'm happy I didn't do it either
till this day listen I lost a child and
I failed as a father but listen when I
went through and I went for it and here
we are today and I can I go to my house
and we [__] laugh I could stand up at
night and without being high me and my
daughter and my wife and giggling and
you can't put a price on that
and that's what this podcast is about
today listen if you're gonna get into a
relationship pursue relationship don't
marry that person especially men I hear
it all the time some guys I had a marry
issue is a piece of ass and then two
years later you were the [__] cord
and listen marry somebody cuz you love
them marry somebody because you they
make you feel complete marry somebody
because you're on a team I think that
Terry for three years four years I was I
was 40-something years old I was a
mediocre comic I was a regular I opened
up for rogue and I really had nothing
going on you know I was booking some
movies and you know what man I was
taking Terry for granted like we all do
we all take people in our lives for
granted sometimes and when I was
shooting The Longest Yard
we went from Santa Fe New Mexico to here
and I had to be a Redondo College every
morning at 4:45 or 5:45 I don't know I
got there when I wanted to because the
they would put tattoos on in and
shoulder pads and all that [__] but I
don't I still don't want particular one
that I got up and my football pants my
t-shirt my socks my sneakers were always
out in the couch and my wife today was
in the kitchen making me breakfast and
it had to be 4:00 in the morning and she
had to be at work at 8:00 you know and I
remember looking at it going this is
what I've been looking for all my life
like this is she's doing this I don't
have money I don't have anything to
offer and she's doing this way and
that's when I started falling in love
with my wife like that's when I started
realizing the love was there you know I
read then I started working at it I
started cleaning up my act
I stopped going to certain places just
because I didn't want to hurt her
feelings but then the last thing came up
and I realized that she was a sweet girl
and I didn't want her you know I find it
I knew that it wouldn't last with me
doing coke I didn't want her to I was
very embarrassed about my drug used
around her I hid it from her as much as
she could but after four years five
years she knew was out and one of the
reasons why I quit coke was because I
didn't want her to find me on the
[__] floor let me tell you something
if you think I gay I did I didn't give a
[__] what my ex-wife did like if she
[__] found me I didn't give a [__]
more power to her more power till she
found me dead and it ruined her life I
didn't give a [__] about it I didn't
think about like that or when I started
thinking about my wife Terry like this
these are all the things that made me
call her up even though I was against
marriage a hundred and fifty percent I
was never gonna do it again I was never
gonna [__] do it again I did it I did
it and I did it the right way from day
one and not because I'm better than you
guys I'm not because I'm smarter than
you guys well it's not because I read a
book on marriage it's because I failed
out of marriage and I knew what it would
take to make a marriage work
so this podcaster day is dedicated to
[__] marriages before you get [__]
married and get married just to have the
wedding in Long Island and Van Halen's
gonna plan your wedding and all that
dumb [__] remember there's more to a
marriage than the [__] wedding there's
being with that person for the rest of
your [__] life
the wedding is DIC compared to being
with that person the rest of your
[__] life so before you make that
decision keep your eyes open because you
don't want it to be what I did my first
marriage has wanted me till today 30
[__] years later dirty is later and
it's gonna haunt me on the 40th
anniversary and on the 50th anniversary
and yet it taught me to be a better man
but at the same time it reminds me the
mistake that I made so by me making this
mistake I wish you guys don't make the
same mistake and that's it [__]
it's Monday morning I want you to go out
there write your [__] goals and put a
knife to these [__] and tell
them it belongs to you you want it back
it's that [__] simple before we get
the [__] out here let me read you some
dates I'm gonna be in Dallas Friday
I think there's 13 tickets left San
Antonio so that Chicago September 27th
at the Chicago theater its tickets are
moving so you better get on and don't
contact me and boy are you gonna add a
second show doubt it
it's a big [__] theater but when it
goes it goes and then I got Kansas City
on the 11th and we just added a new show
in Denver on the 12th the second show at
the Paramount either and that's all
that's happening
let's read - a word from our sponsors
first off everybody is selling to CBD
fluid these days everywhere you go to
liquor stores gas stations [__] up
listen I got the answer it's CBD line
calm it's that easy how do I know
because I lived it I was a client before
we started doing business together I
reached out to them because I enjoyed
their products listen they got the
shatter they got the vape panting and
all the every other way they got the
gummy bears strawberry orange and
raspberry no [__] rock your world
they got the tension that's what I live
off $5,000 grams every night before I go
to bed nappy new-new [__] put your
foot you close your eyes and get ready
to sleep like a [__] listen CBD
lion has third-party lab results up on
their website go to CBD line comm all
the tanks should try the gummy bears
try the Shanna try the vapor now
whatever the [__] you wanna however you
want to ingest your CBD CBD line has it
for you so go to CBD line calm right now
I'm pressing Church at the checkout and
get 20% off your water who does that for
you no body [__] the church is also
brought to you by expressvpn listen I
don't know if you know this or if you
haven't noticed internet privacy is
[__] dead Lee comes to me once a week
that somebody stole is somebody uses
credit card in France something used
something here it's dead you don't and
you don't know what you're gonna get
swiped you don't know if it's at the gas
station online you don't know where it's
gonna go but it's gonna go somewhere no
wrong will expressvpn this is not gonna
happen I'll tell you why
this is why use expressvpn they runs in
the background of your computer or phone
and you can use the internet just like
you normally would
nothing you download the app click the
connect and voila you're protected now
the shields your identity it gives you
no location tracking and it's totally
totally anonymous now you're sitting
there going Joey how do I get this
you're gonna download the expressvpn app
on your computer or phone push one
button and you're protected it's less
than seven dollars a month and it comes
with a 30-day money-back guarantee
now take your internet privacy back
today today the the 9th of September
take it back today and find out how you
can get three months and expressvpn comm
slash shirts I'm gonna give you three
months free that's what I'm gonna give
you three months free when you go to
expressvpn comm slash church grab a pen
that's expressed expr e SS VPN dot-com
slash church for three months when you
buy the one-year package there's an
Express VPN dot-coms last Church to
learn more and take back your privacy
expressvpn go there right now and check
this out it's gonna really help you out
with your internet privacy you're gonna
be happy and oh I know you're listening
and what's tonight baby it's Monday
Night Football
listen I know this weekend you [__] up
yeah I like the Chiefs I like the
tidings
I like the Vikings I like the Eagles but
[__] you didn't buy them
so what [__] good is it shut the [__]
up if you're not gonna betcha
I went 5 for 5 in my head who gives a
[__] who gives a [__] let me ask you
something if you find out of hours on
the street would you pick it up or would
you keep walking like a [__] book
that you are of course you take the
[__] money so why do you keep picking
winners and not bet with these
[__] tell me why are you a
[__] [__] you said you went from
handling five for five
let's go that's why I go to my bookie
it's fast it's easy and they pay when
you win let's face it where you're
betting is just as important as who
you're betting on if you're trying to
buy the NFL baseball MMA whatever my
bookies got it
listen I won't be telling you guys to
bet with them if they weren't the best
do the smart thing if you're gonna bet
football let's see
and back with my bookie whether it's
college football pro football basketball
when it comes down to corner
baseball it's my bookie do you know
you've been on a game after kickoff did
you know that if by the second half it
looks like your bed is gonna lose you
can always take the other side if you're
that kind of guy likes to bet a little
and win a lot you gotta try a parlay if
all your picks come true you multiply
your winnings and no matter who you bet
the NFL season it's the best time of the
year the bet okay so what I'm gonna do
is this I'm gonna double your deposit
today now right now right now before
Monday Night Football use promo code
Church to get you a hundred percent
bonus on your initial deposit of up to
$1,000 who the [__] takes care of you
like your uncle Joey nobody so visit my
bookie Donna Agee today that's my bookie
Don Agee and don't forget to use the
promo code Church CH you are CH when
creating your account to claim your
bonus listen my book is simple you win
look I'm sorry you play you win you get
[__] paid and don't forget to go to
my flavors world every Thursday I'll be
dropping a little video with my bookie
to help you make make picks teach you
how to make bets [__] like that you'll
be saying uncle Joey's my bookie
so don't forget my fault mad flavors
world on Thursday and that's it that's
that
we'll see you [__] Thursday
morning tip top Magoo ready to [__] go
I hope you learned something today I
hope you don't make the same mistakes I
made that's why I talk about these
subjects from time to time I have a
great [__] week enjoy yourself
see you Thursday morning ready to go and
if not I'll see you Friday night in
Dallas or Saturday night in San Antonio
get ready Iraq or I'll see you in
Chicago at the teeth at the Chicago
theater September 27th that's it and
that's that
Lisa at check this [__] me